partez ah ouais quand même ah ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci vous avez beaucoup beaucoup vent
pouvant t1 ce week-end de ce week-end de
moi je sais pas pour vous mais moi j'ai
regardé la reine des neiges délivrer
[Musique]
les étoiles autant
m
hier philippe etchebest qui viendra nous
voir avec hélène darroze et stéphane
rotenberg
il y aura j'espère un petit bras de fer
entre philippe et mokhtari les shows
motards peuvent très bien merci à
stéphane rotenberg hélène darroze et
pivi pas de chauves est applaudie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il va avoir sur l'adversaire tout de
suite je sais ça sert toujours la même
on a versé avant le combat
j'adore vous fait mal c'est tous les
matins comme ça au studio ce top chef
ces normes sont arrivés le matin les
génies toi tu es comme ça un petit peu
hattab réagir maintenant dans une auto
croissant ils arrivent ils marchent ils
voient prendre pendant te dis oh [ __ ]
j'ai fait une connerie je lui dis un
truc et il serre la main de fer il faut
quand même dire par là c'est que pendant
longtemps donc il a toujours mal à
l'aise à cerner moise accord avec
impatience le bras de fer entre philippe
etchebest et moctar ben moctar il prend
ça très au sérieux ces regards s'y perd
je pense que il va il va très mal le
vide mais philippe vous donnerai tout
bien sûr philippe etchebest on les aime
parce que il est comme ça moi que j'aime
bien les gars comme ça tu vois ils
disent qu'ils pensent voilà s'il avait
un truc à dire à gilles verdez il l'a
dit il a un truc à dire un mot
[Rires]
alala à ce bras de fer relatant des vous
n'êtes pas lire il partait à oui quand
même
ah ouais tu vas te réveiller à nos
frères rôle devant toute la france était
allée force à l'émotion c'est commencer
la phase aller retour et c'est comme
cela est légal le bras de fer
il est possible que l'émission
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
[Musique]